at first then i become aware of the
thing as a one
and have to hold fast to it in this its
true character
if in the course of perceiving it
something turns up which contradicts it
this is to be recognized as a reflection
of mine
now there also occur in the perception
various properties which seem to be
properties of the thing
but the thing is a one and we are
conscious that this diversity
by which it would cease to be a one
falls in us
so in point of fact the thing is white
only to our eyes
also tart to our tongue also cubicle to
our touch and so on we get the entire
diversity of these aspects
not from the thing but from ourselves
and they fall asunder in this way for us
because the eye is quite distinct from
the tongue
and so on we are thus
the universal medium in which such
moments are kept apart and each exist
on its own through the fact then that we
regard the characteristic of being a
universal medium
as our reflection we preserve the
self-identity and truth of the thing
it's being a one
in section 119 hegel is going to make a
very important transition
so far we've been talking about things
on the side of the object primarily and
consciousness has been
you might say sort of parasitical upon
the object although
consciousness as we've seen happen
before is really where the
the main show is going on it's just that
consciousness loses sight of that
sometimes and places what's really going
on on the side of the object but hegel
is an idealist
so things are going to fall within the
scope of consciousness
here we're going to see an important
transition take place
not in its full unfolding that's going
to happen in further paragraphs but at
least in its
its beginnings so we want to look at
this incipient
movement and the principles on which
it's based
and what do we see hegel reminding us of
at the very beginning of this
it reads very much like the other
sections at first i become aware of the
thing as a one i hold fast to it and
this is true character if in the course
of perceiving it something turns up
which contradicts it
that's to be recognized as a reflection
of mind so any sort of deception
any sort of you know particularity any
anything that's wrong
is on my side i bear responsibility for
that he said
the object is just what it is or is it
so he goes on and he says there also
occur in the perception various
properties
now notice at this point he's saying
where do we actually perceive the
properties do we perceive them
in the one in the object we'll use this
as an example because i'm tired of
talking about chalk all the time this
blue
cloth which is soft which has the
property of
duct ability or flexibility has certain
size a certain feel to it it's kind of
sound that
maybe you can hear that rustling are
those in the object
or are those in our perception of the
object
this is a term that by the way is taken
in much of
modern philosophy there was a
distinction that was made between
primary and secondary qualities that you
see
lock making a lot of but lock isn't the
first person to come up with this
the notion is that on the side of the
object there are some things that
actually
are properties residing in the object
but there are some things that are only
in our perception of it
so sweetness for example is sweetness
really something that's present there in
the object as sweetness or is that in
how we perceive it the sweetness of
honey for example
it's due to glucose or maybe sucrose or
fructose or
i don't know which which oase is in
honey i'm sure somebody will put it in
the comments
but it doesn't matter that's that's
that's not an important point the point
is
that there's a chemical there in the
thing but the chemical itself doesn't
have a taste it has a taste for
us for a subject for a perceiver
so he says um there there also occur in
the perception various properties which
seem to be properties of the thing
but the thing is a one and we're
conscious that this diversity
by which it would cease to be a one
falls in us
so all these properties if we if we
think of
um honey for example you know as gooey
and you know sticky
and sweet in a certain way
and amber colored although i know
there's other kinds of honey there are
different colors
you don't need to remind me of that if
we think about that
those those properties as properties as
determinant are not really residing in
the thing he's saying but but rather in
our perception of it
so the diversity the
plurality of properties resides somehow
in consciousness
now how can that be well what he's
saying here makes good sense
follow it through he says this diversity
falls in us
so in point of fact the thing is white
only to our eyes
also tart to our tongue also cubicle to
our touch there are organs by which we
are
perceiving these things right
and so on we get the entire diversity of
the aspects not
from the thing but from ourselves or
rather if he's speaking more properly
through
our perception of the thing we grasp
those
properties in perception by means of the
organs through which we perceive sense
perception
and we put them all together then into
something that's like an image or a
picture of that thing that's out there
that we're perceiving or
maybe in there if it were putting
something into our mouths right
so he says um they fall asunder in this
way for us
why because the eye is quite distinct
from the tongue
and so on so we
human beings we perceivers are the
universal medium you remember that we
said that the thing was the universal
medium before
but now hegel is saying no actually the
thing is a unity it's a one
and the universal medium of these
properties is
really in us in consciousness in
the fact that we perceive these things
in multiple ways
and then form them together into a a new
unity
we're the ones who see salt in a variety
of different perspectives we're the ones
who see this blue thing in a variety of
different perspectives by
putting it up to our skin by
rustling it by i don't know this i
suppose this would be a property of you
know
slowly falling or fluttering you know
all of those are things that
we ourselves bring to it we contribute
that to it there you might say they're
in the thing waiting to be liberated but
the thing itself will never liberate
those properties from each other
precisely because it's a unity of them
so
if we go on and he says through this
fact that we regard the characteristic
of being a universal medium as
our reflection that's what allows us to
preserve the self-identity of the
of the thing it's being a one so
we are actually the ones
who are making the thing be a thing and
we are the ones
who through our perception through our
capacities for that and through the
activity that we're engaged in as
conscious beings
make these properties be what they are
but regarded as existing each for itself
in the universal medium
these diverse aspects for which
consciousness accepts responsibility
are specifically determined white is
white only in opposition to black and so
on and the thing is a one
precisely by being opposed to others but
it is not as a one that is that it
excludes others from excel
itself for to be a one is the universal
relating of self to self and the fact
that it is a one rather makes it like
all the others
it is through its determinateness that
the thing excludes
others things are therefore in and for
themselves
determinate they have properties by
which they distinguish themselves from
others
since the property is the thing's own
property or a determinateness
in the thing itself the thing has a
number of properties
for in the first place the thing is what
is true that is it possesses intrinsic
being
and what is in it is there is the
thing's essence and not on account of
other things
secondly therefore the determinant
properties do not only exist on account
of other things and four other things
but in the thing itself yet there are
determinant properties
in it only because they are a plurality
of reciprocally self-differentiating
elements
and thirdly since this is how they are
in the thing hood that is in the essence
of the one thing of which they are
properties they exist in and for
themselves indifferent to one another
it is in truth then that the thing
itself that is white and
also cubicle also tart and so on
in other words the thing is the also or
the universal medium
in which the many properties subsist
apart from one another
without touching or canceling one
another and when so taken the thing is
perceived as
what is true
in section 120 we may see something that
looks a little bit like
a not lack of progress but actually
falling back
into where we just were in section 119
we saw
we were making some progress by turning
to consciousness
and now as we go through this it's going
to sound as if hegel is saying just the
same stuff as he said in the previous
sections
in perception but in actuality that's
not the case it's part of a larger
context in which he is slowly getting us
ready to
continue this transition into focusing
on the side
of the conscious subject so he starts
out by saying regarded as existing each
for itself in the universal medium which
we saw now is on the side of
consciousness these diverse aspects for
which concept consciousness
accepts responsibility are specifically
determined now
what does that mean that means that they
are
distinct from each other and they're
distinct in different ways so he
he gives us an example white is white in
relation to its opposite black
right it's not white just in relation to
it's it's opposite which is not a true
opposite except in the thing
hardness or softness or chalkiness or
tastiness or bitterness or anything like
that
it's a color and it's determined that
way red
is you know in opposition to i suppose
green or in opposition to white or in
opposition to black because it's not
those things
but it's it's not those things in a
different way that it's not the odor of
roses
so he goes on and he says the thing is a
one
for consciousness precisely by
being opposed to others so each
thing each unity is a
one by not being the other thing
the chalk is not the book it's not the
tie it's not the man
it's not the camera and we can go on and
on like that
this book is not the same book as you're
reading because it's
a different copy right this one has
certain properties
though some of those properties are
pretty similar to the one that you would
be reading
but some of them would be different such
as being in dr sandler's hand right now
would you rather contingent property but
you get what i'm saying
so he says um it's not as a one that it
excludes others from itself to be a one
is the universal relating of self to
self we this is stuff that we've seen
already
the fact that it's a one rather makes it
all like the others so we can
talk about unity in general right
being a one and we saw this movement
with
sense perception as well right with
sense certainty
pick any sort of individual object you
like and say
individual object well every object's an
individual object so you haven't really
said an awful lot by saying individual
object
the more that we insist upon
particularity
ironically the more we launch ourselves
into a kind of generality
an empty generality as well that is not
going to contribute an awful lot here
so he says the fact that it's one makes
it like the others it's through its
determinateness
that the one excludes others now how is
the thing
determinate that is where we want to
look at these
properties and hegel is going to have a
little play on words here
using the term eigen
um one's own right proper you could say
and the word for property is
eigenshocked
so literally the the you know condition
or the substantiation of being eigen
being one's own being particular being
specific
and the thing has these properties and
as we've seen these properties are
differentiated not only from
you know white from black things from
their opposites but also from each other
so the whiteness of the salt
is not the same thing as the tartness of
the salt it's not the same thing as the
granularity of the salt this is all kind
of old refresher right
but it's in having these properties as
proper to itself we have just kind of
that word
here with the the proper you know
specific to it
uh the greek would be idiom you know the
word that we get idiot from by the way
there's a different thing going on there
so he says things are
therefore in and for themselves
determinate they have
properties by which they distinguish
themselves from others
since the property is the thing's own
property or determinateness in the thing
itself the thing has a number of
properties that's
you don't have a thing without having
properties that you just have an
empty nothing you would have something
that you couldn't hang anything upon
you couldn't point at it you couldn't
mean it intending it you couldn't
talk about it in language you couldn't
think it
so he goes on and he says um
in the first place the thing is what is
true he's giving you
these three different conditions that
he's going to talk about for what's
going on here
in the first place the thing is what is
true it possesses intrinsic being
and what is in it is there as the things
essence and not
account uh not on account of other
things that's one perspective that you
can take on this
so the property that this thing has in
the case of the chalk the whiteness of
the chalk
is there for the chalk as part of what
that chalk is
it is of the essence of the chalk it
makes that thing
what it is it contributes to the unity
of that thing being that thing
the same would go for any of the other
things that this thing is being
differentiated from
in consciousness and in reality
he says secondly therefore the
determinant properties do not only exist
on account of other things and four
other things but in the thing themselves
but their determinant properties in it
only because they're
as we've seen that's why i've got these
arrows here a plurality of reciprocally
self-differentiating elements now you
know what does that mean a little bit of
refresher
this property is different and distinct
from this property is different and
distinct from this property which is in
turn different and distinct from this
property
they are not what the other is they are
determined
by not being with the other is i use the
metaphor sort of pushing off of each
other
which is probably the most tangible way
that we can think about it and they push
off of each other
without at the same time like turning
the chalk into nothingness
if they were able to overcome that
tension entirely and and you know
shoot away from each other we would be
left with no
thing no unity that we could talk about
but it's because that tension exists
within the thing that we
are able to perceive it as a thing and
as having properties
so thirdly since this is how they are in
the thing hood in the essence of the one
thing of which they are properties they
exist
in and for themselves indifferent to one
another each one of them
is like a little world unto itself the
whiteness of the choice existing
in itself that is being what it is
but also existing for itself you might
say although hegel's not going to go
into this
that the white is doing whiteness and
that's all it really knows or cares
about if
we're being a little bit metaphorical
here and the cubicality
just does you know it's cube thing it
doesn't care about what the white thing
is doing it's indifferent to it
it's also indifferent to whether we're
perceiving that or not
so he goes on and he says um they exist
in
in and for themselves indifferent to one
another it's in truth then that the
thing
itself is white and also cubicle and
heart and so forth
in other words the thing once again
becomes not only a unity
but the also the universal medium
in which the many properties subsist
apart from one another without touching
or canceling
one another when so taken the thing is
perceived as what is true
but notice that all of this
is happening where
the unconsciousness which is carrying
out the
act of perception
now in perceiving in this way
consciousness is at the same time aware
that it is also reflected into itself
and that in perceiving the opposite
moment to the also
turns up but this moment is the unity of
the thing with itself a unity which
excludes difference from itself
accordingly it is this unity which
consciousness has to take upon itself
for the thing itself is the subsistence
of the many diverse and independent
properties
thus we say of the thing it is white
also cubicle and also tart
and so on but insofar as it is white it
is not
cubicle and insofar as it is cubicle and
also white it is not tart and so on
positing these properties as a oneness
is the work of consciousness
alone which therefore has to prevent
them from collapsing
into oneness in the thing to this end it
brings the in so far
in this way preserving the properties as
mutually external and the thing as the
also
quite rightly consciousness makes itself
responsible
for the oneness at first in such a way
that
what was called the property is
represented as
free matter the thing is in this way
raised to the level of a genuine
also since it becomes a collection of
matters
and instead of being a one becomes
merely an enclosing surface
in section 121 we're now going to see
this active role of consciousness
coming to the fore hegel will tell us
that in perceiving this way
consciousness is aware that it's also
reflected into itself okay so that's
something that we've heard many times
before
that's not radically new but what does
that mean in perceiving
the opposite moment to the also turns up
what was the also he also was the thing
in so far as it was a bunch of
properties that existed in a kind of
miasma or soup in which they
you know didn't really interfere with
each other or connect up with each other
so he says in perceiving the opposite
moment to the also it turns up what is
that opposite moment
he says this moment is the unity of the
thing with itself
okay we've also heard that come up
before
that's this movement by which the thing
is is sort of like everything else in
the hegelian universe
becoming other to itself and thereby
introducing these tensions
a lot of really cool stuff goes on but
again
there's something new going on here we
want to ask so he says
this this movement is the unity of the
thing with itself a unity which excludes
different from its difference from
itself so
other things are different it's
excluding them accordingly it's this
unity which consciousness
has to take upon itself the thing itself
is the subsistence of many diverse and
independent properties so how
does consciousness actually do this
this is where we're going to see some
really important active contributions
on the part of consciousness a lot of
people want to
um you know think about hegel in terms
of kant this is one of the areas
where kant would actually be kind of
useful to think about
in part because kant was was saying he's
not the only person saying
this of course but he's one of the
people saying this that our minds are
really
active that the order that the
structure that we perceive in things out
there
isn't necessarily in those things it's
something that we
are imposing upon them through
the faculty of the the understanding by
which we're taking them in even even
with sensibility to a certain extent
the understanding plays a really
important role hegel is not going to
worry at this point about
differentiating these things
he's going to talk in terms of
consciousness but he says
the thing itself is is these diverse and
independent properties so we say of the
thing it
is white it has this property of
whiteness it is
cubicle also cubicle and also tarte and
so on
now he's going to use this term in so
far in sofiane which
if we want to you know be kind of cutesy
with playing on words we could say you
know fair also means far
distancing is going on here i suppose
there's something that could be said
about that but you know
we don't really need that at this point
um but it's kind of an interesting point
to dwell on he says insofar as it's
white it's not
cubicle so we've already seen you know
these properties differentiate from each
other
how do they hold together then in some
sort of unity
that's the the key question that we've
been dealing with we see that there's
this tension
insofar as the thing is a unity these
properties have to be all sort of
congealed together
in so far as they can be properties the
thing can't really be as unified as it
would like it has to be more like a
universal medium in which these
properties are free to be themselves
and you know where is the truth that
somewhere in between
it's been fluctuating back and forth
hasn't it we want to try to hold on to
both ends of the truth at the same time
which is always difficult to do
so he says positing these properties as
a oneness
is a work of consciousness alone
now the thing the thing doesn't posit
these the thing doesn't think these
the thing could bring them into unity
but the thing is actually
rather passive consciousness
that is positing the thing
as a unity it's giving unity to the
thing
literally in german the word for this is
in einsatzem
it is taking the properties and putting
them
into one in eins in in
a unity so i've got this you know
depicted here of course you know
there's a limit to what we can do with
modeling right but each property
is taken up into the thing
by this positing on the part of
consciousness
each property is taken up as being
what the thing is as being connected
with the other
properties as being part of a
unity a way in which the thing is
related to itself
the thing isn't doing that on its own it
is consciousness
which is doing that with the thing and
its properties
that's an achievement to realize that at
this point the activity of consciousness
hegel goes on that's not where the
activity ends
he says um to this end it brings in the
in so far
and where does this in so far come in
the in so far
is at the level of the properties and
this in so far
is what differentiates these properties
from each other right it puts the bar
between this property
and this property and uh
these two between each other right i
know it's getting a little bit messy
here
but you get the idea the in so far says
insofar as this property is what it is
it is not that
consciousness is contributing both of
these at the same time
unity and
difference
how can that be the case how can
something be contributing
something and its opposite at the same
time well that's where we get to see
the hegelian system at work isn't it a
thing
calls for it's very opposite and it
what what's able to do that not things
by themselves
consciousness in a way this is like
going back to
aristotle's dictum that the soul is in a
certain way
all things that it's capable of having
you know a thing in its opposite at the
same time
whereas things can't really do that on
their own
so he's going to go on and he says quite
rightly
consciousness makes itself responsible
again we see this word responsibility
coming up
at first in such a way that what was
called the property is represented
as free matter
material something that actually can
have an
agency of its own the thing is he says
in this way raised to the level of a
genuine
also since it becomes a collection of
matters and instead of being a one
becomes merely an enclosing surface
so we see once again we juggle between
these two viewpoints of
the unity of the thing or the
also of the thing if we want to focus
primarily on the thing then we have to
see it as a unity and then the
properties are kind of subservient to it
and then we have the side
of this positing going on if we want to
see these properties for
what they are then we have to view the
thing
as and also as this indifferent medium
that mirrors the indifferent medium over
here
and then we have a focus on difference
instead
and all this is taking place because of
the agency
of consciousness that we've now
uncovered
you